I'm Stefanie Scott communications and
outreach director from sponsored
projects administration we've heard from
a representative of the libraries we've
heard the perspective of the biomedical
researcher and now you're about to hear
the perspective of spa and I know when
you hear the word spy you're thinking of
candles and massage oils and all that
stuff
no I'm talking about sponsored projects
administration aka the Grant's office
and people tend to have strong reactions
when they hear about the grants office
and central administration but in
hearing both your presentations today I
absolutely feel that we have shared
goals and purpose with these federal
public access mandates and I started
writing down quotes such as smooth the
pass and smooth the path and minimize
administrative burden and and that
really is it is it is how do we enable
researcher success with these OSTP
mandates so going back to the memo that
we referred to of from February 2013 the
office of science technology and policy
every federal agency is implementing a
public access plan for for publications
and for access to digital data so how
are universities going to support this
what have we learned from the NIH public
access policy and what are the questions
that we should be asking ourselves in
central offices now how can we
collaborate with each other more and in
particular well what I'm going to say is
that here at Columbia we've been keeping
our eyes open for each of the federal
agencies rollout of they're implementing
implementation plans and we're now at
the point where some of these plans are
starting to take effect for example NSF
is about to roll out their plan and
they're beginning a pilot project of
their new database to support the public
access of publications and we're having
these conversations so how do we support
researchers how do we ensure compliance
what is the University's role and how
can we encourage compliance as
relates to a researchers career so I
think another important question is how
why is this important to them how can we
communicate this to them what is the
incentive incentives that was the other
thing I quoted from you so so let's talk
about the key offices here who are
involved with discussing these mandates
and let's start talking about the key
areas and the questions that we should
be asking ourselves first let's talk
about my office Spa so when you think
about spa and I talked about the candles
and I talked about the oils really we're
operational in nature so we're a
pre-award office with sometimes
post-award responsibilities we review
proposals for compliance we are a
service oriented department and our
mission is to provide exceptional
service however we don't have the
expertise in dealing with publishers we
don't necessarily understand ourselves
always the benefits of open access and
public access I can tell you you know
I'm working in spa I feel that there are
at times when I feel like I need to be
better educated in the better of the
benefits of open access so I can
communicate it to faculty as it relates
to compliance and so I'm gonna talk a
little bit more about that in the
working collaboratively together to
ensure compliance and to also promote
open access and so of course we've heard
from scholarly communication programs
libraries data management their focus is
a little different from spa because
they're supporting the global reach and
the impact of research they're providing
the tools the data management plans the
increase of the awareness and they
really understand the benefits of open
access and the libraries may provide
system support and the tools to assist
researchers in working with publishers
and some of that hands-on help I also
need to point out here universities like
Columbia and Harvard and some of the
larger institutions
are probably very lucky to have these
resources but smaller universities such
as PU is predominantly undergraduate
institutions may not have these
resources available to them and so as
other organizations are having these
discussions it becomes who's going to
take on what role so in continuing on
some universities may not have a
copyright office or a copyright advisory
officer and these individuals and we do
have one here at Columbia they have
experience of working with publishers
understanding the legal implement
implications of signing copyright
agreements and can encourage faculty to
be aware and be strategic in managing
their copyrights and in this complex
world of publishing and often what I
find that can be a determinant to
compliance is that very often in my
experience faculty or I'm sorry pis and
authors and working with publishers may
not read their copyright agreement fully
and so and may not be able to
communicate well with a publisher about
the federal mandates that they have to
comply with and so all this work
actually happens in the beginning with
that author with the publisher in order
to insurance compliance but I want to
talk a little bit about that more later
on in terms of the challenges the Office
of General Counsel may be involved in
these discussions at your university in
terms of looking at language that could
be negotiated - including copyright
agreements to protect the university and
then let's not also forget the Provost
or academic affairs and their role with
university appointments and defining the
expectations of faculty they provide
role in this as well let's also not
forget in information technology they
may need to come to the table especially
when it comes to data security policies
personally identifiable information
HIPPA requirements and defining certain
costs
and central support that may need to be
that may be needed for supporting data
management and proposals and of course
human subject protections an IRB looking
at the NIH genomic data sharing policy
is a great prime example of where IR
bees are now very much involved with
data sharing and ensuring that
participants of a study are well
informed that their data may that their
data may be used for future use for
other types of studies and so as you can
see I have nine offices listed here on
the screen that need to talk to each
other about these public access mandates
and now let's talk about some of the
areas and the questions that
universities and colleges should be
asking themselves and how we're going to
divvy up these roles and
responsibilities so who's gonna stay on
top of the sponsor policies themselves
and I actually have here it's not just
federal anymore
it's non-federal as well for those of
you that may be familiar with the Health
Research Alliance which is an alliance
of nonprofit foundations they are also
mandating public access policies so
let's not forget that it's not just
federal it's non-federal as well and who
will take on the role of staying current
with the non-uniform way in which all of
these agencies are mandating public
access policies so a big part of this is
defining the role of who will stay
current with the details of all these
implementation plans and policies and
then you have university policies who's
going to revise and maintain university
policies and take on the role of
responsibility for keeping the
institution compliant of course
communications awareness and training is
a huge aspect of this with the research
community in my role in communications
outreach
I've certainly done a lot of training
for faculty and I've learned so much
over the years of what works in terms of
getting faculty to understand their
responsibilities with this and what
doesn't work it's a very complex and
with my experience with the NIH public
access policy I can certainly tell you
it's very complex to communicate it even
in a succinct way so this is can be very
challenging but I've been very fortunate
happy to collaborate very closely with
our libraries in doing this type of
training budgeting guidance so let us
not forget that I think not just
sponsored projects offices but other
offices as well should be talking about
the types of costs what are reasonable
and customary reasonable costs that you
would see in a project proposal to help
support this so publication costs data
management effort data management our
data managers and the allocation of
supplies and equipment and so these
costs you know are allowable but
certainly with constrained funding if we
have these mandates and if for example
an investigator is applying for funding
that may have a cap on total costs for
requesting funding how do we fit this in
and if we can't fit it in a proposal
budget to support it where are those
costs going to come from so this is
something else that we're talking about
as well as trying to come up with some
centralized resources where we're
talking with IT and talking with our
data management experts about what these
costs actually are and so that folks
like me and a spa office can communicate
it and look at it when we're reviewing
proposals to see what is reasonable I
know that in the very beginning we
talked about data management plans
knowing where those reso
knowing where those resources are and
that they exist are extremely important
and I know that my office we communicate
all the time with faculty and
departments to point them to our
libraries that have wonderful templates
and guidance and the expertise to help
develop these plans but it also really
comes up right up front as a faculty is
developing their proposal how do we get
the word out to them that these
resources are available what are the
first step stopgap measures before they
even come to us to submit a proposal
that these words resources are out there
data sharing of course repository
security I mentioned that before human
subjects consent for future use these
are the other discussion points as we're
moving forward and monitoring and
compliance some central offices and
universities that I've talked to
libraries have taken on part of a role
to look at data for example with the NIH
public access policy to look at
non-compliant publications and reach out
to faculty it's not always the library
sometimes sponsored projects offices
have been involved with this and then
sometimes faculty are on their own
to stay on top and be responsible for
where their publications are in the
compliance process
systems support so as each of the
federal agencies are rolling out their
plans as I said you know they're not
uniform
we have NIH that has PubMed Central we
have now NSF and the Department of
Energy working together on what's known
as pages or the public access repository
and so new systems are gonna be popping
up some are going to contract with NIH
and who's going to be the subject matter
experts in learning all these systems
essentially who's going to provide
hands-on trading and do troubleshooting
developing training materials in
learning these systems orchid IDs and
communicating that to faculty to help
them get registered even though it's a
simple process so essentially we're
talking now also about system support
and I've done a little bit of this and
our library certainly do does a bit of
this as well where we have shared
responsibilities but again you know
universities need to talk amongst
themselves and kind of figure out what
role we play with that and as you can
imagine with the IH again public access
policy they have my NCBI they have the
NIH manuscript system we've got PubMed
and PubMed Central and differentiating
what those two things are we now have
sciencv which is another system that's
pulling in publications to help create
investigators biosketches so systems are
becoming more and more complex and this
is one of my favorite bullets actually
which is communications and
communicating with publishers
negotiating copyright agreements and
communicating sponsor requirements to a
publisher right now
you know PI's and authors communicate
directly with them they may not know
exactly how to communicate to them to
negotiate an appropriate copyright
agreement to meet these mandates so it's
it's very complex in terms of giving
faculty the appropriate tools
the I think the ammunition to work with
publishers and then in terms of support
correcting non-compliance which is
something that I have been very involved
with troubleshooting assistance
providing education when we get to a
non-compliant publication for example
and again in my experience with the NIH
public access policy it's already too
late because and let's not forget that
with the NIH public access policy if you
have non-compliant publications they
will withhold and delay your future
funding until they the publication's get
fixed and so actually looking at a
non-compliant publication figuring out
why it's not compliant takes a lot of
effort and so universities have to talk
about who's going to help support the
faculty when we have non compliance
issues because they can be quite tricky
and complex to fix in fact there is no
quick fix okay well there we go see I
touched on some of these points already
challenges so far that we've experienced
prevent how can we educate faculty to
prevent publication non-compliance
because it really starts with the
communications that take place between
the author's and the publishers if those
talks don't happen right upfront in
terms of a sponsors requirements and
ensuring that the appropriate checks are
boxed off at a copyright agreement then
you could get potential non-compliance
down the road and increasing pressure to
sign copyright agreements without
reading fully what it says so especially
possibly with junior faculty or those
just starting out they want to get
published and so there's tremendous
pressure to sign these agreements to
have that publication out there I
thought here's another issue in terms of
communications is that so much
responsibility has put has been put on
the PI to comply they're also
responsible for communicating with all
potential author
on a grant so grad students postdocs
collaborators overseas sub recipients
that may be publishing off of a PI's
award they have to comply with any
publications that they write as well
with the public access policy but they
may forget or they may not be aware that
they have these compliance obligations
and it winds up being the PI's
responsibility to communicate with all
potential authors but again that's not
necessarily their first priority with
their research publication management
the lack of ability to delegate the
management in the administrative aspects
of this has been quite a challenge so
and if I think it's difficult to have
administrators be able to manage and
associate ok these publications are
related to these particular awards
because they are not the scientists and
they're not necessarily familiar with
the outputs of a particular grant and so
that has been a challenge
so that again there's more
responsibility on a principal
investigator to comply because it's very
difficult to delegate the administrative
aspects of that to other folks and then
finally when you have these really large
institutional training grants and multi
project grants it could certainly get
very hairy in terms of keeping track of
compliance and I know I'm talking a lot
about publications because that's where
I've learned where a lot of the
challenges are as opposed to data
sharing and data management but I think
there's also still so much offices like
us in Spa that we are still learning
concerning the challenges of data
sharing and data management so I don't
know if this is the best graphic in the
world I got three big circles I have
sponsored projects administration on the
top and I have the scholarly
communications program and the libraries
over here and everyone else I put in the
nice purple circle but I think really
what the the point I'm trying to make
here is that we can't have any more
silos these public access mandates are
so complex folks like myself need to be
better educated
to be able to communicate to faculty in
terms of how to comply and we all need
to I think learn from each other I need
to learn a little bit more about the
roles of the library I need to learn a
little bit more about Faculty's
priorities and then you it would be
helpful to also have libraries and
faculty a little learn a little bit more
about our role as well so that we can
all support each other
for reducing faculty administrative
burden so I think what's also difficult
as faculty are looking for support for
this is as you can see from my nine
offices there's too many central offices
to go to to get to go for help there
isn't really one key individual that you
could possibly go to to help you with
all different aspects of this so and I
talked about educating each other better
understanding I think of all of our
offices that the benefits of open access
will foster better communication with
faculty and again understanding what's
important to faculty is extremely
important for all of us so that we can
advocate for them which is my next slide
and I think one of the most important
slides how can we advocate for faculty
to reduce administrative burden and so
there are several professional
organizations and I want to talk very
just briefly about them and I know the
library's also has professional
organizations and maybe this is the time
where the chocolate meat needs to meet
the peanut butter and we can work
closely with each other to help advocate
for our faculty so this is the federal
demonstration partnership just to give
you a little bit about the federal
demonstration partnership it is a
cooperative initiative consisting of ten
federal agencies and I believe we have
over a hundred sixty institutional
recipie institutions that are involved
in the federal demonstration partnership
this is where federal agencies and
universities roll up their sleeves and
they talk about how can we reduce
administrative burden associated with
federal research grants and
tracts and in 2012 the FDP conducted a
survey of principal investigators of
federally funded projects to determine
the impact of federal regulations and
requirements on the research process and
so they had over 13,000 pis respond to
the survey they had a twenty six percent
response rate this survey the results of
the survey it's very interesting you
could go to the FDP org it is all there
the executive summary as well as the
full report and here's the key and I'm
quoting here from the executive summary
P is reported that almost half of their
available research time for federal
projects had to be allocated to project
related requirements instead of the
content of their research projects P is
estimated an average of 42 percent of
their research time associated with
federally funded projects was spent on
meeting requirements rather than
conducting active research okay this is
very important
42% and in that 42% and in that report
and I won't go into all the details of
that report they do talk about data
sharing and how much time and is taken
away from their research in order to
meet these responsibilities including
certain aspects of interpreting adapting
to changing federal requirements for
data sharing posting data and other
resources such as software and curricula
as required by federal funding agencies
clearing and posting publications to
federal repositories D identifying and
refining data to meet federal
requirements for data sharing and
completing training regarding data
sharing requirements on federal projects
and I won't talk too much more but again
the goal is to try to reduce
administrative burden partnerships like
the federal demonstration partnership is
a great way to bring awareness to work
with federal agencies in terms of
possibly coming up with a demonstration
pilot to collect more qualitative and
quantitative data and the amount of time
it may take to meet some of these
federal man
and so I think now is the time to start
working with some of our federal
partners and collected some of this
information to do whatever we can to
reduce the amount of systems available
or the lack of uniformity so that we
could better support researchers and
have them conduct more research you know
spend more time doing research I also
through the other organizations up such
as the Council on governmental relations
and Kira and SRA the Society of research
administrators International which are
also open forms for us to discuss these
issues together so finally I'll just
leave off this is the time for colleges
and universities to form a central
workgroup or task force talk about
blended roles and key individuals who
are going to share responsibilities and
become aware of these different issues
trained faculty jointly do whatever we
can to develop comprehensive but simple
resources to help support faculty and
let us all advocate together so I leave
that as my final words and I want to
thank you very much
[Applause]